foreign
[Music]
and
we're here to talk to you about
protecting your sensitive data right
so a few years ago Scott and I launched
here cloud data loss prevention
and we aim to bring you a core set of
tools to help you to protect and
classify your sensitive data so that you
could reduce your data's risk through
its life cycle
today we're excited to share with you
that we're expanding beyond the lp to
sensitive data protection
while important data loss prevention is
really just one use case that we see our
customers apply our tools to
while this new expansion will bring you
more tools and new features cloud data
loss prevention and the DLP API aren't
going anywhere we're not going to have
you have to migrate or redo any code or
redo any Integrations you'll find that
all in our new home here
we'll also continue powering workspace
DLP and DLP Chrome and Beyond core
Enterprise so those services will
continue benefiting from all of our
investments and improved discoverability
and improved detection models while we
now invest more in other areas
one of the two key new components that
we're investing in is what we call the
discovery service which we're going to
talk a little bit about next
so Discovery is a service that
automatically generates sensitive data
profiles all of all of your data in an
organization it helps you determine
where your sensitive data is so that you
can help protect it and make sure that
you're doing all the things you want to
do
there's no jobs there's no code some
users would write inspect jobs and
manually try to build their own
Discovery service so this takes care of
that for you with automatically
automatic generation and orchestration
of these profiles it currently supports
bigquery and big lake and will be
expanding the cloud SQL before the end
of the year
once Discovery has been enabled in your
organization there's a lot of different
ways in which you can use the produce
data sensitive profiles from the console
the profile gives you a starting point
to just see general information about
the data sensitivity and data risk of
all of your data and tools to
investigate who has been using those
that how how the data is being used and
how what you're doing right now to
protect it
foreign
there's also a new level of granular
reporting data profiles go all the way
to the column level and so in this
example I have a column that's actually
been classified as a credit card number
so the data the profile will tell you
hey we think this is a credit card
number we think this is a social
security number we think this is some
sort of medical identifier we'll go all
the way into the column and tell you and
tell you whether you've done anything to
protect it is it public does it have
proper policy tags on it
we'll also tell you things like is this
structured or unstructured which might
indicate more risk of more data
information hiding in there
of course we have hundreds of detectors
that this works with and you can also
customize what data you think is
sensitive because sometimes your data
needs and what you consider sensitive
aren't the common ones like credit card
numbers
you can also include all of the normal
custom detectors that you've known that
we've had with DLP API
now the easiest way to turn this on is
to just turn it on for your whole work
one click turn it on and go but we know
that most companies want to start slow
and try sampling in a smaller group and
so you can choose to select a folder or
a project or projects and start
profiling only data within those small
areas before you go and turn it on for
the entire organization
you can also choose when tables are
reprofiled so you might choose that hey
I trust where the data comes from this I
only want to reprofile this if a schema
changes but I have another table where
the data is coming in from a third party
I don't really trust I don't know how
good of a job they're validating that
they're not sending me data they
shouldn't be and so those tables you
could choose to reprofile
every week every day whenever a data
changes at whatever Cadence you'd like
you also have options to control when to
do backfills so we obviously have a lot
of data sitting in here already and you
might not have the budget the profile
everything all at once and so you can
choose to set backfill time stamps to
say only start profiling tables for the
last quarter or three months and then
slowly move that clock back as you have
budget to profile older data
you can also set things like minimum row
count which helps you not profile data
too fast so employee creates a new table
they haven't really populated it with
enough data signals for us to get a good
profile of you can ask us to wait and
wait until it has enough Data before we
profile it
of course all of these controls can be
customized and configured for different
data sets projects folders tables you
can set up regular expression patterns
and set up the combination of rules and
patterns to just best suit your needs
you can even set up so like say you
disable all profiling on your test
generated projects but maybe turn on
more frequent profiling for a data set
that is say a public folder or your
payroll data
we have two modes of billing for this
there's consumption billing and
subscriptions there's also a free tool
to help you pick which one would best
suit your company's size and needs
once you've enabled Discovery there's a
lot of different connections where we
surface data profiles to help you with
your operations
we have free out of the box reporting
using liquor Studio which gives a great
bird's eye view of your organization's
sensitive data and it's really useful
for auditing and Reporting
we also can enrich your Cloud security
and secops by sending these profiles
into Chronicle and security Command
Center so having this data alongside
your threats and vulnerabilities lets
you prioritize your security work based
on the sensitivity of the impacted data
data Ops teams can also leverage these
signals from right within dataplex so if
they're doing a search or an audit
across your entire organization and
they're combining and searching with
business tags they can also combine in
search with the data profiles in this
data sensitivity
lastly since Discovery runs continuously
you can build custom alerting or
event-driven orchestration using Cloud
Pub sub
this could be useful for automating
policy changes or automating remediation
or building customer alerting to alert
you say when a table goes from low risk
to high risk and you had thought it had
no data data of concern
Scott's actually going to Now demo for
you that now that we've turned this on
for an organization how you can also
take other actions with the data
profiles
thank you
great thanks Jordana
okay here we're going to switch over to
the demo
and um
we're going to walk through how you can
Leverage The Discovery and the results
to really take action to better protect
your data
and for this demo we're going to
introduce Angie who's a data compliance
officer for a large Financial Financial
firm
and Angie has a problem they call really
an ocean of data
and it's just full of unknowns and the
way they look at it is there's about
five percent of the data that they
really understand well and they know
it's sensitive
there's about five percent they know
isn't sensitive and then about 90 they
just don't even know about sometimes
they don't even know it exists and a lot
of times they just don't have control or
kind of visibility into what's going on
there
and this is what we want to try to help
Angie solve today
so the first question is really how can
I get a view
across of the data across my
organization even the data that I don't
know about the data Maybe that's sitting
in those projects that are in my org but
no one's self-reporting it they're not
showing up in any dashboards at the
moment how can I get that kind of wide
visibility
so we're going to use the discovery tool
that Jordana mentioned and we're going
to go in and look at a live dashboard
this is on our test Organization for
Angie and this is an example of that
bird's eye view we've been running it
for a little while we can see that
aggregate view of all the data that
we've profiled it's a very highly
sensitive org now at the very bottom
here we can see a daily activity chart
every day the summary of the data that
we found and the risk profile of that
data
and you can see here that there's been
some pretty big spikes even recently of
a lot of highly sensitive data that came
into the organization
and again this just gives a little bit
of that
um heartbeat of the organization someone
goes in and creates a project creates
maybe some tables in that project this
will just pick them up profile them and
show up on the report here
now from this bird's eye view
you might want to drill down and look at
something like in this case what region
what geographic region is that data in
so we can slice it and drill down by by
Cloud region or geographic region here
or drill down and look all the way down
again to a table or an individual column
so in this case we've drilled down to a
particular area where we have data
coming in from a partner
that we use that data but it looks like
we found some very highly sensitive data
that was unexpected
so we're going to go here from the
dashboard and we're going to go into the
cloud console view of that table
now what we see here is the table
profile
and down below we see the individual
column profile of every column in that
table
and we can see here
that we have one column here that's
payment card information it's highly
unique credit card numbers so we see
that ranking there that it's highly
unique
and what that means is that it's likely
that every single value in that row is a
unique credit card number as opposed to
a low unique score would be something
like the same card repeated over and
over and over again so again this is all
information to try to help us understand
the types of data and the size and shape
of that data
so the first thing we really want to
look at is who can access this data and
who has been accessing this data
so from here we can see
the detailed IM permissions
and we can see for our organization that
the entire data engineering team has
access to this table
so that's a concern everyone in the data
engineering team can access this table
they have an access Grant at the data
set level or at the table level
next we're going to jump into Cloud
logging
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to look
as you see in this report we're going to
pull a report of all the accesses over
the last 30 days on this table
and as this loads in
we see
some accesses in the past week
and then we see some accesses up here
we're just going to look at this first
one here a couple weeks ago one of our
data Engineers went in and queried this
table and from the access logs
we can see who the actor was it was
someone named Scott it wasn't me but it
was someone else at the company named
Scott
and we can get down and even see
all of the fields that they queried
so this is a listing of all the fields
in that table that were queried so we
know
just from this log that about two weeks
ago Scott went in and viewed all this
data and we know from the profile that
there was highly sensitive data in there
so now we have both answers here but we
have too wide of an access a lot of
people can access this data and now we
have evidence that somebody went in and
saw the data that maybe shouldn't have
seen it
so really we've Angie's discovered this
kind of anomaly a highly sensitive table
with people that have accessed it in
this case we see again that Scott has
gone in and accessed those particular
fields
and it turns out
um
that Scott has a reason for accessing
this table
and so really the next question is how
can they move to a more least privileged
model without creating unnecessary
friction
now in this case that data engineer
needs to run an aggregate database all
right so aggregate dashboard where they
look at the payment types and they
aggregate the most popular payment types
so they take that data they throw it
into their bi tool and they run that
imagine a pie chart of different payment
types with the largest amount being the
biggest pie chart
but in doing that they're really going
into that table and doing a select star
and pulling all that data down
so we want to allow Scott to still run
that query
but we don't want those sensitive fields
to be part of that access
so let's go back to this data profile
and to fix this we're going to use
something called bigquery policy tags
so from here
we're going to go into bigquery and
we're going to just look at what the
table looks like at the moment
so we see here this is in bigquery
bigqueries view we see the schema we see
those sensitive information Fields here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to apply a policy tag to the
actual fields in that table now for this
demo I've created a copy
of this table just so we can kind of see
the side-by-side comparison so this is
that same table where we've gone in and
applied policy tags on the individual
fields
to see the little warning that we see
next to those
but the payment type and the transaction
amount is still available so I can run
my dashboard report if I was running
that you know count or group by payment
type
but let me go ahead and query the table
here
and let's say I do a select star
just like that log showed before
we're going to run this query and you
notice I got a result it came back no
errors were generated but there's a
warning message that said
your data's been masked and we see if
you look at all the fields
a lot of them are reporting null even
though those fields are actually have
data in them and what we're doing here
is we're creating that balance between
granting access to the state engineer
that needs to see those certain Fields
but restricting access to the highly
sensitive Fields like contact
information and payment card data so I
can still run my analysis as long as I
don't need to use those sensitive Fields
I don't have access to
now the reason that we set that up is we
wanted that statement to work a select
star still works if we jump into the
data security policy that we set up
what we're going to see here
is that this policy we've categorized
our data into a couple different
categories
we'll zoom in here to these financial
and pii categories we can see here that
we put a policy on those called nullify
and that's why we're getting back just
no results for all of those columns
whenever I tag something so in this case
I tag something credit card number it
rolls up to that Financial policy which
nullifies it for those users you can
also put in a loud deny policy or other
types of masking and allow deny policy
would have rejected my query if I
included the fields I'm not supposed to
see again you can find the right balance
for what you need
great so we've solved this kind of least
privileged problem with that with
minimal friction we didn't have to go in
and make you know copies of the table
and have different access lists and
everything we can apply those policy
tags and get that fine-grained access
control while still technically sharing
that whole data set with the with the
entire data engineering team in this
case
so next let's say we want to be able to
detect and mask structured and
unstructured data at query time now what
we just showed was taking that profile
tagging The Columns and applying that
master so applying that mask at query
time but what if we actually wanted to
use our engine and inspect the data and
mask it as part of our SQL so for this
we're going to go in
um and we're going to show what's called
a user-defined function in bigquery
which will actually call our engine live
as part of the query and for this we're
gonna we're gonna use this this demo set
here
zoom in a little bit
so we have a very simple query that has
four rows of data
we're going to run this
and you'll notice that in in our test
data set which is sitting right here
rows one two and four
are the same value
and what we're doing is we are hunting
for email addresses
and we are using our deterministic
encryption to tokenize that data so
you'll notice in the results rows one
two and four are getting the same value
Row three is a different value
now just to kind of emphasize that point
and why that's important let's run that
same query but let's wrap it with a
aggregate query so what we're going to
do is we're going to count the email
addresses
but we're going to tokenize them first
and what you see here is as expected we
get one email address now tokenized has
three values count of three and the
other one has a count of one and the
reason we're showing this is when you
run tokenized data like this you can
still run joins you can still Run
Aggregates but the actual data is hidden
through our tokenization it's obfuscated
and so we can do that at query time and
see that masking right here
now the full power of our engine also
allows you to do this on unstructured
data so if we run a very similar query
here
in that First Column which says
encrypted what we're seeing is we've
actually hunted for the email address
inside and in this case also a phone
number inside of the sentence inside of
the cell and only encrypted that part so
you also have the ability to process it
on unstructured data and this particular
method is reversible
so we show that in the third column we
can actually take the encrypted value
put it back in and with permission
reverse it back to the raw data so it's
a very powerful back and forth engine
you can choose one-way methods or
two-way methods but this kind of shows
you that end to end
and what's important here
is let's say that you had a particular
table
in this case let's say we had email and
notes in a table and we wanted to run
this on one of our tables and create a
copy that we could then share out to
others so in this case what we're doing
is we're running that masking of the
email address masking of the email
inside of the note field
but we can actually now materialize this
view or this result and then share that
table or save it if we needed to send it
out outside of bigquery so again this is
another way you can actually manipulate
the data so that when you materialize it
it's now stored at rest in an obfuscated
form
and what's really cool about this
[Music]
um
system here is it can also work on just
about any table that bigquery can access
so here's me running that same query but
on an external table so this table
actually lives in Cloud SQL
in a I think it's a postgres database
we're running that same query but you'll
notice that the from I'm actually doing
an external table query on the on the
destination but I'm doing that same
select statement with our user defined
function
and again we get those results out but
this is querying a cloud SQL database
now
so really anywhere that bigquery is UDS
or user-defined functions can be run you
can now leverage this to manipulate your
data and again maybe materialize it
somewhere else
and it's actually not limited to
bigquery uh this isn't a screenshot of
us doing a very similar UDF calling our
same DLP system but running in Snowflake
SAS system
so from here as you can see we have a
very similar encrypted DLP function
and in this case we've done different
manipulations it's a very flexible
system to do partial masking
or full encryption as we see here with
the card number it's revealing every
masking everything with the last four
digits and on the social security number
it's doing a full encryption and then we
applied it to some data inside of the
note field in this case again hunting
for certain data types
so we wanted to show that that's really
how we can help Angie in this case take
action protect the data
and we showed some of this stuff going
Beyond discovery that sort of inline
masking and now I'm going to pass it
back to Jordana to go in more depth
about some of the stuff you can do
Beyond discovery
oh
yeah
there we go
so we've shared with you Discovery but
as I mentioned since the data protection
is meant to cover more than just the
discovery service
the cloud DLP API still lives on and we
still have a lot of other services from
within the console we offer apis and a
native Cloud console tool to inspect
data storage systems including Google
cloud storage bigquery and data store
and even custom storage systems using
our hybrid apis to investigate and find
individual findings
this is really useful when you need
really precise details about where
exactly all your sensitive data is for
often use cases around de-identifying it
we also have tools to help you measure
privacy Risk by looking at statistical
anomalies and common re-identification
metrics these re-identification metrics
help you inform you on the likelihood
that someone could reverse engineer who
data belongs to or who it identifies
from the console and our apis we offer a
number of de-identification solutions
Which Scott has just demoed a few of
they come in both API forum and we have
native support for data sitting in cloud
storage
we have many Advanced masking techniques
across structured and unstructured data
which can be used virtually anywhere as
he showed
importantly your data analysts and your
researchers can leverage these
techniques to tokenize data while
keeping referential Integrity so no more
saying well I need to have the email
addresses for anything you don't need
the email addresses please tokenize it
just don't risk it and these tools are
super easy to use and they won't
interfere with their jobs and their
ability to use the data
our platform and our apis are super
useful in protecting your AI and your
machine learn your machine learning
workloads you can remove sensitive Data
before ever training on it or you can
use it when customers interact with you
as the data comes in from the customers
and the queries or as you send responses
back our apis are fast enough to serve
that traffic in real time
tomorrow morning there's going to be a
talk at 11 on data governance and
generative AI that I encourage you all
to go to to think more about this
our de-identification platform is also
built into the contact center AI so this
lets you choose how and when to
transform your customer sensitive Data
before it's used in insights and
training it's fully customizable by
using a de-identification template so
that you can Define when and how and
what it does so whether it does full
redaction or tokenization or masking or
some other technique
so in summary sensitive data protection
enables you to understand your data
manage that data's risk
while still being able to use that data
for all of your important workloads
to get started you can turn on data
profiles for free for 20 tables and some
of our consumption apis also have free
tiers you can also check out dialogflow
workspace dllp or beyondcore which are
all powered by sensitive data protection
thank you
foreign